who's got the energy to be racist huh  that's gotta suck to be racist wouldn't  that be weird just like you go to the  bank you're like ah this jew's here i  gotta leave what a horrible life  man put on an outfit go to a meeting all  that stuff i don't care about any group  enough to hate it do it whatever you  want go nuts i don't i don't want to do  anything i'm lazy  i don't want to burn a cross or a  calorie yeah  everybody's worked up on something these  there's muslims on airplanes i'd rather  a muslim on a plane than a baby  never had a muslim kick the back of my  seat and piss in the aisle  i'm just saying if the airport had a  baby ban i wouldn't protest